you know we saw these sclerotic things
corrupt institutions that had all this
trust and we kind of ripped the um you
know the facade off and showed people
that there were these huge flaws and I
think I seemed great like what's the
downside to that and now find ourselves
in a world where all the institutions
are in trouble I mean I don't think this
is actually all that media specific I
think there's a decline across
institutions and you can get very
focused on like did the New York Times
do something wrong what it is a global
right sort of cross a broad base yeah
but I think this moment of technological
shift and it turns out I think having
trusted institutions is probably pretty
valuable and you look at I mean covet
was a good example countries like you
know Australia and South Korea that had
really highly trusted institutions seem
to have done better than most of the
western yeah well we could get into that
but in the United States we would be
right not to trust the institution right
but here's the thing and the tricky
thing when I'll speak about media which
is like the one I know best which is we
were always right not to trust them like
I mean I was in we were I was in
newsrooms and you know the late 90s I
was in and and you know you could like
us yeah I was covering cops in
Indianapolis in 1999 and you know there
would be a shooting and we would have
the wrong name of the shooter the wrong
name of the victim go knock on the wrong
door be running around like total idiots
all day and by the end of the day I
would have sorted some of that stuff out
and the story that was published the
next day would actually be mostly
accurate but occasionally inaccurate
would correct but now but that all we
were all you know but now we you know a
shooting happens and journalists are
running around like idiots trying to
have the wrong name and the wrongness
the wrong that and trying to sort it out
and people are like Jesus you guys are
such idiots but of course we were always
idiots it's just like now you can see it
right and I think that's true of a lot
of these institutions and so that's
how you create a kind of trust when
people can actually see what idiots you
are right when you own the mistakes
right yeah one but I mean when you can't
create this kind of Mystique that was
never really Justified so let me ask you
two questions that relate to BuzzFeed uh
part of what we talked about where you
guys debunked the mega story which is
that Russian interference in the 2000
election particularly in places like
Facebook that's what tipped you know the
balance to Trump who you know one with
less than 47 of the popular vote
squeaked in you guys debunked that but
that seems to be a very strong narrative
that people still kind of persistence
yes
um but then you also made the decision
to publish the Steele dossier which was
originally compiled by uh people who
were related to Hillary Clinton's
campaign or it was used in that term
most of this and you'll remember the
steel dossier was the source of the idea
that there was a the P tape of Donald
Trump when which I hope for God even if
it's true it never sees the light of day
because I already have nightmares but
um you know can you talk a little bit
about like most of the steel dossier has
been debunked yeah
um what went into your decision making
to say okay we're going with this and
then what what's the effect of something
like that on trusted media
um
it's a good question I mean I think you
know I certainly came to that decision
and in general to
you know with with like the sort of
Gawker mindset in a way that
we should be saying to our audience the
same thing we're saying to each other
that there's it seems crazy that you and
I would have a conversation and then a
lawyer doctor teacher construction
worker who is in our audience would say
hey what are you talking about we'd be
like sorry you're not smart enough to
understand this
um and so when we got the dust and a lot
of journals have been given the dossier
by um it was compiled by actually at the
point that time very well regarded
former British spy involved in the FIFA
investigations and knew a lot of
journalists from that which is a
fantastic book about all of them yes too
which is worth reading whose name of
course I'm Gary Meyer yeah yeah great
book
um and
and
and so and we like I think everybody
else got we got the essay later and
threw a weird side door and so we
weren't bound to secrecy but also we did
I think what everybody else did we sent
a reporter to Prague to see if she could
figure out if Michael Cohen had been
there she went from hotel to hotel
showing his picture and it's amazing
people at hotels I guess in Prague at
least we'll just check their guest
registry for you wow If you're sort of a
Charming friendly and reporter
apparently
um and and went to Moscow to talk to see
if anybody at the Ritz Carlton would
discuss this with us
um and and I think you know I was
already thinking like huh like at some
point we should like every journalist in
Washington has seen this thing all the
intelligence officials a lot of the
Senators Harry Reid has written an open
letter to James Comey saying he knows
that Comey has compromising information
on Trump demanding he release it McCain
is acting super weird in a way that you
don't really understand unless you know
about this so at some point you're kind
of like this is like this is the dark
matter of Washington that every and
everyone is in on it except for the
reader it's hard to explain what's going
on actually without some reference
Institute and it's starting to bleed
into the public a little and so we're
thinking about like how do we cover it
and then and but then this is where it
wasn't really like this Grand principle
like there's a very specific thing that
happens which is CNN reports that
this previously secret document has been
briefed to two presidents to the
President Obama and president-elect
Trump and that it is full of it and that
it alleges that Trump was compromised by
the Russians and at that point to me
it's like I'm holding my hands a list of
suspected Communists in the state
department like you can't show the
document you cannot report on it
which is where we were but you can't
show it and then say but it'll burn your
eyes out if you look at it right I just
think that's not a tenable position so
that's why we published it